if you see a suspended production of the
hit reality show bachelor in paradise
amid reported allegations of sexual
misconduct on the set the latest season
featuring 16 contestants was shooting in
Mexico it was set to premiere in August
Warner Brothers the show's producer says
it is now conducting a thorough
investigation of the allegations and
will take appropriate responsive action
Kevin Frazier from our partners at
Entertainment Tonight is in Los Angeles
Kevin good morning what's happening here
good morning Gail you know the bachelor
in paradise features former contestants
from the bachelor and bachelorette and
they are encouraged to find love amid a
atmosphere that is a full of drinking
and also drama but now the show faces
legal repercussions over workplace
misconduct The Bachelor returns to
paradise after three seasons of bringing
together bachelors and bachelorettes
ABC's hit reality show bachelor in
paradise is now on hold after
allegations of inappropriate behavior on
set all of the contestants including
Robbie Hayes were sent home what about
the show getting canceled or will it
restart we'll have to wait to see Warner
Brothers since the fourth season of the
show had just started filming in Mexico
where they shot last season a source
close to the production tells
Entertainment Tonight after the cast had
been drinking all day two contestants
ended up naked in a pool as cameras were
rolling details about what happened next
are unclear but the source says the
female contestant was quote out of it
and doesn't remember much of anything
adding their stuff that shouldn't have
happened
the source says a producer felt
uncomfortable and claimed misconduct in
the workplace as sexy new singles swing
in looking to get wet and wild now the
show is suspended for the first time in
the 15 year ABC franchise and faces the
possibility the entire season could be
scrapped why you think you may cry
producers are walking a very thin line
on the one hand wanting to create
exciting television involving sex and
alcohol and on the other hand
protecting the safety of their employees
and the cast members themselves the show
could now face legal repercussions from
both the contestants involved and
employees by allowing the participants
to engage in sexual activity and
fuelling it with alcohol a Warner
Brothers a Time Warner may very well
have created a hostile work environment
for everybody involved
now as of now the Mexican police have
told CBS this morning that they have not
been contacted about a potential crime
and the network has made no change to
the original August 8th airdate Nora all
right Kevin thank you so much